uh why don't we go next to
uh there's just so many people here why
don't we try nathan from rhode island
nathan you are on the air what's going
on today
hey david can you hear me
yes i can great so uh going back to the
pandemic um i have a question about the
future
sure um the washington post put out a
couple of weeks ago an article talking
about um how devastating future
pandemics could be the who in december
came out with a report saying future
pandemic should be even worse than this
one
um given that 1.7 or 1.7 million people
have died as a result of the pandemic
globally
um and we have cons considerable media
push uh uh presenting evidence of
individuals who have been anti-vacs who
have been hospitalized and died some of
these have been uh republican and
conservative activists
my question to you is what do you think
it would take
for the typical anti-government folk to
take a national crisis seriously or
global crisis seriously if
not not even the individuals who are
dying can convince the people that they
have cultivated in these these circles
to
to move forward and get the vaccine
well what you have to understand is some
of these people are genuinely just
stupid people that's that's one aspect
of it
the uh there is a contingent here
that
it's not really even about the specifics
of the crisis it's just their
philosophy
is government shouldn't really be doing
stuff they see a government not doing
anything
as a good thing that's that's what they
want they they enjoy that they think
that that's what makes the most sense so
what you have to understand is it's not
really about even convincing them x is
serious
it's you have to disabuse them of the
ideology that starts at government
probably shouldn't do anything period
and that's a really difficult thing to
do which is why i and many others are
questioning whether we really have a
path out of this type of nonsense
yeah but do you to a degree do you
believe that there's a segment of that
population who are just the contrarians
who are who who are probably in a
community surrounded by people who are
like-minded like that and yes and so how
do we how do we convince the folks who
might have have a light of seeing
because because they you know they say
go vote they they advocate for or some
of them advocate for policies not
recently but
you know they they seem like they they
understand that government has a place
even if they say oh i love small
government oh the government should be
the size of the bathtub or whatever be
able to be drowned in a bathtub they
their their actions speak that yes
government has a role how do we convince
them that
that public health specifically on a
societal level is one of the the
foundational aspects of a functioning
society and we've been doing i mean this
is um there's a few so so that's
it's really a more general question of
how do you convince people to re-examine
their beliefs so one one approach would
be
you
ask them in a sort of standard socratic
way
how they came to hold the general
philosophy about government that they
hold and then you show them that their
philosophy is compatible with public
health being a valid
area for government to be involved you
try to show them that you don't even
have to change your beliefs you just
need to understand that your beliefs
point to this is an area where
government should be involved because
it's too big for it to be dealt with
locally and it's you know whatever right
you kind of have to
show them this is one of those areas
where government should be involved with
some people that might work with others
it's the personal connection with some
of them when someone they know does get
sick and or die
that's what's going to do it there's no
one answer to that and that's what makes
it very difficult but all of these are
approaches that can work
awesome i appreciate your time thanks
david my pleasure appreciate the call
it's it's an important question i just
wish there were clearer answers right i
think that's the the difficulty